このあと僕の髪型は
こ～いう前髪にしたいです。
ここが短くて、こっちがすごい長くて、目が片方隠れてる、、、
片目隠したいんですよね。
ちょっとかっこいい気がしちゃう、、、
中二病とかいうんじゃないよ？
こんにちわ！はじめしゃちょーです！
みなさん！
斎藤さんっていうアプリご存知でしょうか？
結構昔ね、めっちゃくっちゃ流行ってたんですけど
最近はどうなのかな？
斎藤さんってアプリはですね～
パット聞くと怖いですね！
もう昔使ったからな～もうみんな知ってると思うんですけど
なに！カラオケ機能とかついてんの！今！
今回はこの斎藤さんをやっていこうと思います！
で今回はこの斎藤さんを使って何をしようかといいますと。
僕なんか声が特徴的じゃないですか～
なんか低くもないし高くもない声変わり失敗したような感じ！
果たして斎藤さんをやってみるとはじめしゃちょーと
バレるのかどうかっていうのをやってみたいと思います！
あの僕、コミ障なんですよ！僕コミュ障です！
なんかテンション高いときは全然いけるんですけど！
基本的に人見知りしちゃうんで！
ちょっとこの斎藤さんを使って僕の人見知りを直すのも含めて！
僕の声ではじめしゃちょーってばれるのかどうかっていうのを今回やっていこうと思います！
なんかね偽物が多いかもしれないから～！
もう今回はっきりはじめしゃちょーっていう名前で行きます！
いくぜ～～～！！！
ひっひっひっひっひっひっひ！
ああぁ～ん💛出会いは求めてないですよ！
もう純粋に本当に話したいだけなんで！
斎藤さんと話す！
？？「もしも～し？」
ああ～もしもし！
こんにちは～
？？「こんにちわ～」
あ、、、
いい天気ですね、、、
？？「んん？」
むり～話せない～うわ～
あー怖い怖い怖い怖い怖い怖い怖い
無理無理無理無理無理無理無理！
本当に無理！ほんと無理！
女の子　だぁねぇ
こんにちわ、、、
あ、もしもし？
もしもし、お疲れ様でーす
聞こえてますかー？
はじめしゃちょーですこんにちは
もしもーし　　こんばんわ～
はじめしゃちょーです
本当に喋れない💦
マジ無理
やぁだ、だめだ、冷静を保てないな
もしもし？あ、こんば、、
こんにちは
声がダサいからなー
意外とバレないですねー　こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーっすか？
えっ　なんでわかったの？
はじめしゃちょーっすか！？
なんでわかったの？
本物×２
いや、ほんと。　本物本物！
本物、本物！
声そっくりじゃなくて本物本物
じゃまたねーありがとねー
ん～いい人だった
うわぁ〜なんか楽しく！
斎藤さん楽しいね！
一回やっぱ疑われます。本物かどうか
こんにちは
いまですね
+％*+><+?`*=)
もしもしーこんにちはー
こ、こん、こんばんわー
あ、二人いるの？
あらこんにちは
あ、あのー
あのボクはじめしゃちょーっていうんですけど
泣かないでー
今どこ？学校にいるの？
こんにちわー
私はじめしゃちょーと申しますー
はい　よろしくお願いします
はじめしゃちょーってご存知ですか
あ、そうなんですよ
今ですね、ちょっと動画撮っているんですけど
YouTube 見られますか
お、本当ですか
誰見られますか
もしもし
あ、もしもし？　こんにちわー
私はじめしゃちょーと申します
あ、初めましてー
よろしくお願いします
あの、はじめしゃちょーってご存知ですか？
そうなんですよ　よくわかりましたねー
見たことありますか？
またよかったら見てくださいね
こんにちは
もしもしー　　聞こえますかー
ボクはじめしゃちょーです
本物ですよ
マジじゃん！　えっマジじゃん！！　やばいやばい・・・・・・
こんにちわー
はじめしゃちょーと申します
ヴぁやああああああああ！！！
やっぴー↑
こんにちは
初めまして。はじめしゃちょーと申します
本当ですよ
わかります？
本物ですよ
ほんとですよ！
♪タータタタタータータタタタータタタタータータタタタータタ　タタタタータータパッパッパッパパパパ♪